this presentation is about the breeding
of impatiens royal arana to develop
plants that are resistant
to impatiens downing mildew
before i begin my presentation i'd like
to explain a little bit about long run
about cornell university's campus on
long island
the long island horticulture research
extension center is located on the east
end of long island in the city of
riverhead
we are about 315 miles southeast of the
main campus in ithaca
the research center is located in
suffolk county the leading crop
agricultural county in the state of new
york there is no other county in new
york that is more diverse than suffolk
county
agriculture and horticulture industries
developed in suffolk county
because of the environmental factors
that
are good for plant growth there are
fertile well-drained soils
we are in a unique climatic zone of usda
zone seven
which is considerably warmer than
upstate new york there's plenty of fresh
water and underground aquifers and
plenty of sunlight
with the large markets that are just to
the west of suffolk county
the agriculture community receives very
high returns on their investments
the long island horticulture research
and extension center is one of a kind in
the united states we are the only
horticultural research and extension
center
that has professionals that represent
each of the commodity areas as well as
the cross disciplines
we have specialists in the greenhouse of
floriculture industry
specialists in the food industry with a
specialization in grapes and viticulture
with specialists and vegetables as well
as
woody ornamentals which covers the turf
industry the nursery industry as well as
plant maintenance
addition we have cross-commodity
specialists we have two plant
pathologists
for plant disease
we have a weed scientist we have two
entomologists for insects and bugs and
we have a plant tissue culture
specialist
impatience while ariana
was the most popular bedding plant in
the united states up until about 2011.
it's so popular because it comes in a
variety of colors almost every color
except yellow and a true blue
it's also plant that grows very nicely
in the shade it can even grow in the sun
if it's irrigated properly
the plants are propagated by seed
which is a benefit to the commercial
producers it reduces their costs for
production of this plant and they get a
higher markup
in 2010
the value of impatience in the united
states was 151 million dollars
in the state of new york the value of
impatience was 10.4 million dollars in
sales
but then in patients downing milder hit
the united states and by 2011 the value
of impatience in new york went from 10.4
million down to 1 million dollars
in patients downing mildews of fungal
disease is from the species plasmopera
doosans
it was first reported in the united
states in 2004
it entered the united states in a
hurricane that traveled from africa to
florida
the spores were released in florida and
then the prevailing winds along the east
coast spread this the disease up the
entire eastern coast the united states
by 2011
it is reported across most of the
inhabited world it's globally
distributed
this particular disease can be
controlled by fungicides but the
fungicides that are used are restricted
in the united states and can only be
applied by greenhouse professionals
once the plants leave the greenhouse to
the homeowner's yard
there is no control
that works on this particular disease
this is what happens to a homeowner's
planting of impatience
the photo on the left looks what a nice
planting of impatiens would look like
around the base of a tree
the photo on the right is what they look
like the very same plants after they've
been attacked by impatiens down in
mildew
they lose their leaves they lose their
flowers and all that remains are these
stems
and about three weeks later the entire
plant dies
it's fairly amazing how quickly this
impatiens downing mildew will kill a
plant
it's fairly easy to tell if you have
impatiens down in mildew
turn the leaf
to the underside and look if you see a
white colorations a white fuzzy kind of
colorations that's the spores of the
impatiens down in mildew
the plants the photo on the left
in the forefront show the two plants
that are controls that are filled those
have impatiens down in milden you can
see that they've lost most of their
leaves and their flowers the plants in
the background of that photo are some of
our resistant hybrids
they are still green leafy and quite
healthy looking
once a plant gets in patients down in
mildew there's no cure
and it is a systemic disease it will
never leave the plant
the disease will also remain in the soil
after a plant has been infected so
future years it will re-inoculate new
plants that are planted
the objective of our breeding program
was to use integrasive hybridization
to regenerate resistant plants
we searched for species
of impatients from around the world that
were resistant
to this disease and then cross them with
impatience while we're anna to produce
interspecific hybrids
that would be resistant
you may be familiar with the new guinean
patients which is a different species
that's in patients outcry
they are resistant to a patient's downy
mildew but unfortunately they are not
compatible with impatience while ariana
in 2013 our ornamental plant pathologist
marjorie daughtry
did some preliminary research looking at
ten different
species of impatiens
these this
graph kind of shows you the results of
her research she had five species that
were susceptible to patients down in
mildew and five species that were
resistant
we followed up with this research later
a few years later and we looked at about
40 to 50 different species in our
patients we collected seeds and cuttings
from around the world
grew the plants and then tested them
we set up a screening criteria to
evaluate all of our plants
from zero to five zero being the best
plants and five being the worst plants
if they were ranked with a zero or one
they were
what we considered resistant plants
anything above a one we considered to be
susceptible
these are some of the plants that we
evaluated and we in this particular
table you can see the column on the left
are the species of
that are susceptible to downing milk
the species on the right
are resistant
we use those species in our
hybridization program
to cross within patients while we're
hannah
this just gives you an idea of what we
did
we would take a susceptible species like
the impatiens volariana on the left
and cross it with one of the resistant
species to produce
a hybrid plant
in addition to looking for resistance to
the disease we also evaluated the plants
on their flower color their growth habit
and their ease of growth and propagation
this is another example shown
on the top left
a hybrid of impatiens wallarana
that was crossed with a resistant
species
and you can see in the bottom of the
slide the resulting hybrid which is
quite attractive
during our breeding we used embryo
rescue as a technique to be very helpful
for two main reasons one is that
impatiens have explosive seed pods that
means as the ovary ripens the seed will
explode and scatter the seeds everywhere
by placing
these seeds into
tissue culture we were able to recover
all the seeds that were generated
in addition
by producing seeds in vitro
we were able to have a sterile germplasm
bank for all of our hybrids for future
use
the process is pretty straightforward
we would remove
ovaries about 13 days after pollination
we would take them to our tissue culture
laboratory
and working under the laminar flow hood
we would sterilize them in 95
ethanol and flame them
the ovaries would then be
cut open
and the ovules would be aseptically
removed and placed on a quarter strength
muricious goog medium with only a
quarter strength sugar
they would then be labeled
wrapped with parafilm and placed in the
dark until they germinate which is
anywhere between 15 and 20 days
sometimes a little bit longer
once the seeds germinated we had little
seedlings we would subculture the seeds
the seedlings excuse me onto into
individual culture tubes we would be
able to track them better by placing
them in a tube and giving them an id
number
as the plants grew we would propagate
them and then we would
divide them so that we would have a
clone in vitro and have a clone out in
the greenhouse
the plants in the greenhouse were then
grown until they can be propagated for
us to sufficiently produce enough
replications for the field
at about 2016
we had two hybrids
that were generated that would be
completely resistant to a patient's
downing mildew this was the primary
research of james keach who was getting
his phd with us at the time
we then used these two original plants
to generate everything else that
followed we took these two
lines
we self pollinate them and we cross
pollinate them
and we generated
hundreds of hybrids from these plants
these new hybrids then
were propagated
they were clonally divided so that we
could trial them out in the field and
test them for resistance
and after that
we selected the plants that were
resistant
approximately one-third of our plants
were resistant from these first crosses
the others were susceptible and they
were tossed
following years
2018
we continued to self and cross pollinate
the resistant plants
grew them up in the greenhouse
propagated them and then trialled them
in the field
we discarded anything that was
susceptible
and we we kept the plants
that were resistant
by 2019 we had 30 superior
impatience plants
that were resistant to the downy mildew
we have
all colors of impatience except for a
true white
this gives you an example of what some
of our score sheets look like
we had the number
of the the accession number of the plant
in the left column
we kept track of what the parentage was
of that plant and then their average
score
remember that the lower the number
the better the plant
and anything under the number one was
considered acceptable
anything higher than one was not
acceptable
this shows you how we do some of our
trials we have two hoop houses out in
the field that are covered by 50 shade
we grow the plants in black plastic
with drip tubing underneath the black
plastic
they are grown
outside until
the downy mildew hits usually it's at
the end of august or early september
and then we go and evaluate each plant
once a week
until the plant is dead
for long island we often don't get a
killing frost until the end of october
so
we'll be out there taking data for
an extensive period of time
so we're at the point now
that we're taking these main
plants
and trying to inbreed them to produce
homozygous lines so that eventually we
can produce f1 hybrids
our goal is to produce lines of
impatiens
that can be propagated by seeds
this is our team from this year this
past year they've been working
on this project
we've been very fortunate to have some
great students graduate and
undergraduate students work on this
project
i'll be happy to answer questions later
thank you